el consumidor vive hoy sometido a un
proceso llamado infoxicación que
significa intoxicación de información de
hecho todos recibimos más de 3000
impactos publicitarios cada día y la
marca sabe qué difícil es dejar esa
huella ese recuerdo y solamente le
quedan cuatro opciones
o te repites o sorprendes enamoras o te
olvidan lo primero es caro
lo segundo es difícil lo tercero es aún
más difícil y lo cuarto es dramático
para la marca
el amor hoy en donde a todo desde que
nacemos hasta que morimos y es quizás
una de las definiciones más difícil en
cualquier idioma pero me quedo una frase
de la madre teresa que decía que amar es
darlo todo hasta que duela
en estos años que he estado investigando
sobre la neurociencia aplicada a los
negocios
el llamado neuromarketing me ha
sorprendido la enorme similitud que
existe entre como nos enamoramos de una
persona y cómo nos enamoramos de una
marca
de hecho en el neuromarketing queremos
comprender cuáles son las conexiones
emocionales que hay entre un mensaje
publicitario y por ejemplo una marca
somos seres racionales pero también
emocionales e intuitivos como ingeniero
me enseñaron a solucionar los problemas
del mundo usando la ciencia o la
tecnología pero debo reconocer que jamás
mandaron de la palabra amor en la
universidad
de media nos vamos a enamorar siete
veces en la vida y quiero hablar de
siete pilares básicos que muchas
empresas están usando en el mundo para
enamorar a sus clientes vayamos con la
primera la buena marca marca
me crié en un barrio de málaga donde
nació y vivió pablo picasso
quizás el genio de la pintura universal
más conocido y todavía recuerdo el
lamento de una vecina que atesoraba un
pequeño cuadro pintado en la etapa
infantil de picasso al que le faltaba
algo muy importante le faltaba la firma
la firma de un cuadro
es lo que marca el valor de ese cuadro
no el cuadro en sí y aquí estamos viendo
un claro ejemplo de lo importante que es
la marca
en este
cuadro podemos observar como en un
estudio de investigación vinculado a
cuánto tiempo tiene que estar un
una marca un logo en un anuncio
publicitario que aproximadamente puede
ser de unos 200 a 300 milisegundos es
decir de dos a tres décimas de segundo
pero en el caso de marcas renombradas
marcas que dejan huella marcas que
tenemos en el corazón podemos reducirlo
a unos 80 milisegundos es decir 4 o 5
veces menos de manera que el formato
publicitario puede ser mucho más
efectivo con mucho menos tiempo de hecho
en este caso concreto en sólo tres
segundos más de 100 consumidores
demostraron que era posible tener no una
ni dos sino hasta tres recuerdos de esa
marca en tan poquito tiempo
es muy importante que sepamos medir cómo
poder llegar a eso
aquello que se ama se recuerda quiero
contarles una historia bastante dura que
me ocurrió con 22 años
me impactó un vehículo cuando viajaba en
mi moto y salté por los aires con
muñecos de trapo
fueron unos segundos donde pensaba que
eran los últimos segundos de mi vida
pero ocurrió algo fascinante empezar a
recordar miles de imágenes por segundo
que tenían algo en común eran imágenes
que viví con mis seres queridos con las
personas que más amé ese concepto que
básicamente me hizo recordar escenas con
dos o tres añitos cuando mi madre me
besaba y acariciaba algo que mi cerebro
adulto había olvidado desde hacía muchos
años y ese concepto en ciencia se llama
experiencia de revisión de vida life
review experience que fue ha sido
estudiado por una universidad israel y
ha demostrado que el patrón que yo viví
es el mismo que viven miles de personas
en el mundo que han sufrido ese evento
así que aquello que vivimos con pasión
con nuestros seres queridos dejan en
nuestro hipocampo una memoria que nos
dejan otro tipo de eventos
y con respecto a la memoria hay muchas
universidades que están investigando
sobre cómo la memoria es plástica como
nuestro cerebro también es plástico y de
hecho no recordamos aquello que hemos
vivido sino que recordamos a aquellos
que hemos recordado de lo que hemos
vivido antes voy a intentar descifrar
este jeroglífico sería como si hemos
vivido una experiencia muy buena con una
marca sí cuando volvemos a recordarlo
nos encontramos tristes desolados
angustiados vamos a recordar esa marca
no con tanto optimismo y eso se está
empleando mucha terapia tanto en
psicología como psiquiatría porque
podemos modificar los recuerdos del
pasado para poder vivir más felices en
el presente y en el futuro
de hecho por ejemplo con el olfato sale
descubierto que podemos llegar a
describir y detectar más de un millón de
olores mucho más de lo que pensábamos
hace unos años y además podemos llegar a
recordar casi un tercio de lo que hemos
sólo olido durante nuestra vida frente a
un 6 por ciento de lo que hemos visto o
un 2 por ciento de lo que hemos oído
de hecho si tenemos la enorme mala
suerte de quedar en una cena romántica
ciegas con una persona si usamos el
mismo perfume que usó una ex pareja de
aquella persona con la que sufrió esa
noche lo tenemos ya todo perdido
adrenalina para enamorar
ni bombones ni cena romántica ni rosas
lo mejor para enamorar es la adrenalina
eso se descubrió en un estudio de
investigación en vancouver sobre dos
puentes en río capilano se situaba una
encuestadora en medio de ambos puentes y
uno de ellos era un puente estable
rígido convencional y otra era un puerto
un puente colgante que originaba estrés
a cualquier turista la encuestadora
atendía a los hombres practicando la
encuesta y al final les entregaba una
nota con su teléfono y le comentaban que
sí tenían cualquier tipo de consulta
adicional no duden en llamarla muchos
hombres cayeron en la trampa se
enamoraron y llamaron a esta
encuestadora pero ocurrió algo
estadísticamente significativo y era que
un 450 por ciento más de hombres
llamaron el caso del puente colgante se
descubrió que era real y na la emoción
nos hace enamorarnos y eso me sirvió una
vez para un amigo mi amigo antonio
llevaba meses enamorado de una compañera
del trabajo darle un sabio consejo
nuestro caso invitó a esa amiga a un fin
de semana tirándose desde un puente al
vacío el famoso puente
así que al día siguiente el lunes llamé
a antonio le dije qué tal cómo te ha ido
la respuesta fue
si está enamorado tienes razón pero no
de mí sino del monitor de puenting
así que cuando hablamos de amor tenemos
que tener en cuenta que hay muchos
factores que tenemos que tener en cuenta
me gusta la fe a lo equivocado me
gustaría disfrutar de la fe a cada
segundo de mi vida el proceso del
enamoramiento es de los más complejos
que se producen en el cerebro
interactúan más de 30 áreas del cerebro
incluido el hipocampo el hipotálamo
nunca accumbens la amígdala la ínsula la
corteza prefrontal pero también influyen
ciertas sustancias químicas llamadas
neurotransmisores y hay una que es la
fenil útil
amina la fea quien junto con la dopamina
nos permiten llegar a un nivel de
felicidad extremo superior al de
cualquier anfetamina pero tiene un
efecto secundario y es que se produce
las de conexión amígdala es decir
bloquea el funcionamiento del araper
frontal izquierda la responsable de la
razón por eso cuando nos enamoramos nos
hacemos más tontos pero son más felices
todo lo vemos de color de rosa
esto lo medimos en un estudio de
investigación sobre cuál era la
interacción que tenían ciertos turistas
en el caminito del rey un famoso
caminito colgante que inauguró el rey
alfonso 13 hace más de 100 años en uno
de los mayores acantilados del mundo
resultó que la experiencia que vivieron
los turistas hasta desde la neurociencia
era un 80 por ciento superior al de una
tarde de compras en un centro comercial
y encima era más barato así que con eso
estamos viendo qué importante es la
emoción ame sin preguntas que yo te
amaré sin respuestas seguro
que no sabemos todos los factores que
hacen que estemos enamorados de una
persona al igual que tampoco sabemos
porque queremos ciertas marcas respecto
a otras y esto este tipo de razones son
las que han permitido que sepamos hoy
día por la ciencia que más del 80 por
ciento de las decisiones de compra
obedecen a factores irracionales de
hecho cada día cuando investigó me fío
menos de las encuestas de logro de los
grupos focales de las entrevistas porque
muchas veces el cliente ni me dice lo
que siente sino peor aún ni sabe lo que
siente y en este caso por ejemplo en un
estudio de investigación celebrado en
panamá para poder determinar cuál era el
impacto publicitario necesario para
alentar al voto entre los más jóvenes
quisimos investigar ciertos spots de
servicios
usando los packers usando los neuro
sensores usando los equipos de detección
que américa en la piel o incluso la
detección de micro expresiones faciales
y nos encontrábamos con eventos como
este una persona en teoría viendo un
vídeo muy positivo que tenía un nivel de
frustración tristeza angustia muy
elevado y el nivel de felicidad por los
velos al finalizar le pregunté a este
sujeto
como le ha parecido el vídeo y la
respuesta fue me ha parecido fascinante
que bonita historia del hijo con el
abuelo con el hijo con la maestra
es decir si hubiese basado en la
entrevista había estado totalmente
equivocado
marcas que se humanizan no hay nada más
atractivo para el ser humano que una
mirada de otro ser humano y sobre todo
que una sonrisa y de hecho las marcas
saben que tienen que humanizar la marca
a través de
embajadores celebrities influenciadores
como queramos llamarlo y además en
algunas investigaciones en este caso fue
en el mundo de la moda
hicimos determinar si cuando queremos
vender una imagen con una prenda
tenemos que usar modelos inexpresivos
inertes esos que parecen sacados de
ultratumba o queremos sin embargo usar
modelos expresivos con sentimientos con
sonrisa o usar incluso como en este caso
personajes famosos la conclusión fue que
aunque sí que es cierto que usando
personas con vida
teníamos menos fijación ocular en la
prenda y por supuesto la marca pero la
conexión emocional era mucho más grande
y al final el recuerdo de marca era
mucho mejor es decir tenemos que medir
por dentro para poder actuar por fuera y
comprender cómo son los seres humanos
en otro caso intentando comprender cuál
eran los factores que teníamos en el
biomuseo de panamá para poder mejorar la
experiencia de los turistas el factor
número uno no fue el contenido del museo
ni siquiera fue el edificio tan hermoso
diseñado por un famoso arquitecto lo más
importante en el museo eran los guías
eran esos jóvenes guías que con esa
sonrisa y esa pasión transmitían al
mundo lo que panamá hizo por todos es
decir sin ese museo sin esos guías la
experiencia no sería la misma
el tiempo pasa y no vuelva atrás
quiero contarles que hay marcas que
sobreviven
durante cientos de años y otras otras
marcas que mueren pero lo que sí que
sabemos es que todos nosotros ninguno de
nosotros va a poder vivir eternamente
por lo que tenemos que recordar a
nuestros seres queridos continuamente
cuánto les amamos y cuánto nos importan
y las marcas deberían recordar a sus
clientes cuánto las aman y cuánto les
importa eso fue un caso que nos ocurrió
en un macroestudio con escuelas
infantiles en españa donde queríamos
determinar la conexión de padres con los
colegios a la hora de elegir un centro
educativo y resultó que nos encontramos
con un dato aberrante los educadores
tenían una visión propia mucho más baja
que la que tenían los los mismos padres
mientras que ellos pensaban que eran
simples cuidadores de niños pequeños los
padres sabían que eran los responsables
muy responsables del futuro de sus hijos
lo más importante para ellos así que
simplemente el hecho de poder recordarle
a esos educadores que importante era
para
de sus hijos podría incrementar el nivel
y la experiencia de esos niños en esos
colegios y por último me gustaría
contarle una historia vital que viví
hace muchos años mi padre para mí era lo
más importante en mi vida fue mi
referente y de hecho fue quien me
inculcó la pasión por la educación el
último día del trabajo cuando se jubiló
le acompañe a recoger las pertenencias
del aula de clase que había estado
utilizando durante décadas como
catedrático para dar sus clases se
empezó a sentir mal y no podía
imaginarme que esa noche iba a acabar en
la unidad de cuidados intensivos en coma
profundo
durante más de un mes recorría todos los
días más de 300 kilómetros para ir dos
minutos a ver a mi padre y tocarle sus
manos acariciarle sus manos todos los
días salvo un día que por cuestiones de
trabajo me resultó imposible hacer el
viaje
ese día mi padre abrió los ojos por
última vez
y tuvo algo de fuerza para preguntar a
mis hermanos que donde estaba su hijo
néstor perdí la oportunidad y al cabo de
los días mi padre antonio
murió en la clínica san antonio y fue
enterrado en el cementerio de san
antonio curiosidades del destino pero
aprendí algo muy importante
que todos los días que llamo mi madre
que se encuentra enferma a más de 10.000
kilómetros no para decirle que es la
mejor madre del mundo mamá te quiero
y les quiero dejar un último consejo un
consejo que pueden aplicar a sus seres
queridos o pueden aplicar a sus clientes
el amor es lo único que cuando se
reparte crece por eso amen amen mucho
amen con toda su alma gracias
[Aplausos]